pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fidel castro vient de jeter un énorme
pavé dans la mare des relations etats
unis cuba
dans le discours qu'il a prononcé en
dépit de sa maladie au premier congrès
des jeunesses latino américaine il a
annoncé l'expropriation et la
nationalisation des compagnies
américaine de cuba
cette décision touche des affaires
telles que la compagnie cubaine
d'électricité laisse aux standards et la
texaco dont la valeur s'élève à quelques
400 milliards d'anciens francs
nouvel épisode dans la tension américano
cubaines
recours à léopoldville de monsieur
lumumba a jeté le pays dans une nouvelle
fier le gouvernement congolais a décrété
la fermeture immédiate des consulats
belges et l'expulsion du baron van der
burgh chef de la mission diplomatique
belge par la force si nécessaire selon
les termes du décret cette décision a
suscité devant l'ambassade gardé par les
forces de l'onu
une manifestation hostile c'est au
milieu des cris et des menaces que les
couleurs belges ont été amenés et que
l'ambassadeur a pris la route de
l'aéroport
[Musique]
la veille par ailleurs le parti de
l'abako qui est le parti du président de
la république monsieur kasavubu avait
rompu avec monsieur lumumba au cours
d'une manifestation des slogans vengeurs
accroché à son nom la qualification de
vauriens l'abako réclame maintenant une
confédération des provinces autonomes du
congo confusion et chaos
ce sont les seuls terne dont on puisse
aujourd'hui encore qualifié la situation
[Musique]
c'est dans ce climat que venant de
léopoldville monsieur marshall n'a
atterri à elisabethville pour mettre en
place le dispositif d'installation des
casques bleus au katanga
monsieur tshombe qui a proclamé
l'indépendance du katanga l'a accueilli
avec moins de froideur que ne le
présageait ses récentes déclarations
le secrétaire général des nations unies
était accompagné de 200 casques bleus
suédois avant garde des forces de l'onu
dont monsieur marche elle devenait
négocier la substitution aux forces
belges
l'accord s'est fait l'onu occupera le
katanga mais sans s'immiscer dans la
politique intérieure du congo monsieur
john b et monsieur lumumba reste donc
face à face l'épreuve de force
aura-t-elle lieu
[Musique]
c'est donc en france le téléphone
possède au centre national d'études des
télécommunications
ces laboratoires hier souvenez-vous
l'abonné devait être doué d'une certaine
patience aujourd'hui dans bien des
relations plus d'intermédiaires le
cadran suffit à marseille le résultat
obtenu avec les centres aux automatique
et sans aucun doute déjà très
remarquable mais le cnt expérimente déjà
le prototype du central téléphonique de
l'avenir électronique et quand historiés
capable d'effectuer quatre cent mille
opérations à la seconde dotés de mémoire
le cerveau électronique dirigera toutes
les opérations établissements et
surveillance des communications et même
leur taxation la qualité du son des
appareils va se mettre au goût du jour
en adoptant comme les postes de radio
les transistors et c'est dans le domaine
des liaisons téléphoniques que le
progrès apparaît le plus spectaculaire
depuis 1938 déjà on remplace les anciens
câble qui comprenait de nombreux fils
par de nouveaux câbles moins encombrant
les câbles coaxiaux constitué en général
de deux paires de tubes
chaque paire acheminant 900
communications simultanées lieu sur la
même ligne on utilisera les silences
d'une conversation pour en faire passer
une autre
exemple phase numéro 1 phrase numéro
deux à la transmission les mots de la
phrase numéro 2 s'intercale dans les
silences de la phrase numéro un à la
réception chaque auditeur ne recevra que
la phrase qui lui est destinée voyons
plus loin encore les ingénieurs se
prépare à doubler le réseau hertzien qui
acheminent déjà des communications
téléphoniques et les programmes de
télévision les câbles de l'avenir seront
peut-être cru si l'on peut dire les
guide d'onde seront capables d'acheminer
100000 communications simultanées
[Musique]
après demain enfin les fusées vont avoir
leur rôle à jouer
grâce à elle des satellites artificiels
seront lancées autour de la terre pour
servir de relais relais simple et même
de relais double jusqu'aux antipodes
pour nos conversations quotidiennes
depuis la première transmission
téléphonique de la voix humaine
que de chemin parcouru il n'ya pourtant
guère plus de 80 ans
[Musique]
l'hélicoptère est devenue la machine à
tout faire et ses services sont rarement
aussi appréciable quand montagne où
depuis quelques années sa mise en oeuvre
a permis la modernisation la
reconstruction de nombreux refuges
le dernier rabat dans les alpes et le
refuge des grand mulet intégralement
rebâti en un temps record grâce à
l'élite à terre et qui vient d'être
inauguré le sport ne perd pas ses droits
pour cette cérémonie qui aura nécessité
de la part des officiels l'ascension
d'une partie de la route du mont blanc
du plan de l'éguille jusqu'à 3000 50
mètres d'altitude
allez prends du glacier des bossons sur
lequel est juché le nouveau refuge
le haut commissaire à la jeunesse et aux
sports maurice herzl bien présidé à
l'ouverture
mulet et son hélicoptère piloté par
serge ces sourds et part aussitôt vers
une nouvelle mission une mission dont il
ne reviendra pas l'un des principaux
artisans des grands brûlés serge sessou
pilot alpin chevronnés et on est prévôt
son mécanicien s'écrase avec leur
appareil quelques heures après
l'inauguration dans les séracs et de
l'acompte mobile la montagne a pris sa
revanche
serge de c'est sous lui avaient arraché
bien des alpinistes en difficulté mais
c'est lui que les guides redescendre
aujourd'hui victime de la tragique
fatalité montagnat
[Musique]
dernière séance d'entraînement des
sélectionnés olympiques français avant
les jeux droite et dans la glace du
centre de nogent les rameurs huit
étudiants bassin les nouveaux aviron
opel très un kurde et dont ils sont
dotés de pulpe et deux fois par jour
depuis le début du stage l'équipe
descend et remonte à la roue pour
aligner 25 km quotidiens si mercier le
doubs et viau qui avaient fui barreaux
mais n'a d'yeux ou moroni et clerc
auront ainsi totalisé en six semaines à
la rame à distance de paris à marseille
avant d'aller à rome se mesurer aux
meilleures équipes mondiales
[Musique]
les sélectionnés pour l'athlétisme sont
au même moment au repos à fontainebleau
aucune activité particulière ne leur est
plus imposée
voici idriss chazine
fournier bernard piquemal et sion
la valette du stage et abdou sèye qui va
rencontrer en match amical l'indien
milkha singh l'un des meilleurs et des
plus étranges coureurs du monde que 400
m de passage en france avant les jeux
drame
très attendu ce 400 mètres va être à la
hauteur des prévisions les plus
optimistes chose pour cei qui se laisse
distancer dès le départ et accusent
jusqu'à 10 mètres de retard sur milkha
singh se maintient en deuxième position
[Musique]
le dernier virage syphon de remonter son
handicap milkha singh est passé en tête
et soutient son effort cei se rapproche
des îles à trop forcer et ne peut plus
rien contre singh qui réalise le
meilleur temps jamais fait en france 45
secondes 8/10
selon longueur cole harbour réussi 7 m
soit la perche balastre 4 m 10
si le 4 mai prochain le sommet à kampala
est fondée par le sprinter des bahamas
robinson devant jocelyn de l'état
et maintenant rendez vous aux jeux
olympiques
[Musique]